my name is Robert as as Carlos said I'm
here to talk to you about how to be a
10x analyst and so let's get right into
it I'll tell you a little bit about
myself and why I'm here in a second but
let's get to the punch line because
that's the the meaty part of this
uh so it's actually quite simple to be a
10x analyst you simply need to make
everyone else 10x less effective this is
your simplest and most Surefire strategy
um
after all relative Effectiveness is a
ratio metric and we're all
analytics-minded people here
racial metrics are often more drivable
through the denominator right so while
you can increase your own Effectiveness
it's often way more effective to
decrease the effectiveness of everyone
else by sabotaging their work
here's a plot that drives this home
sorry I can't get through this with a
straight face all right so your
Effectiveness is on the y-axis average
Effectiveness is on the x-axis and you
have this 10x analyst Line This contour
line along which you have constant
relative Effectiveness notice if you
decrease average Effectiveness you
yourself have to be less effective
commensurately
making your job easier so even if you
don't want to sabotage your team you
still should because it'll make it your
job easier so
all right so I have two tips for you and
then we'll end the talk
um one encourage others to work on
interesting projects with ambiguous
value so a great way to do this is to
Simply nerd snipe people
um for example you might say hey hey
John uh I read this amazing 17-page
paper on causal attribution you should
use this on your dashboard
um number two make it so your work can't
be reused by anybody else so for this I
like to implement a strategy of just
making only dashboards and trying to
make as many as I can so this has two
advantages one you know dashboards are a
little contextless so people can't
actually read anything or understand
what you're doing but two it creates the
needle in the haystack problem for
people so you can end up just forcing
them to sift through thousands of things
and they'll never be able to find your
work all right
uh here's here's a sabotage manual from
the CIA
um so lots of great tips here you should
make speeches bring up irrelevant issues
haggle over precise wording the lever
that this is pointing to is to Simply
waste time I'd say uh take this with a
grain of salt don't use it too much
because obviously we're dealing with a
ratio metric if you decrease both both
the numerator and denominator you won't
actually increase your relative
Effectiveness
um
okay so obviously I'm kidding uh and
sorry for that ridiculous bit
uh but I bring this up for two reasons
and I start the talk like this for two
reasons uh one is because
um a lot of the levers that I pointed
out that you can use to really push down
your team are the same levers that we
can use to push up your team and
actually become a more effective analyst
but I'll get to that during the course
of this talk and secondly I want to
distance myself a bit from this concept
of the 10x engineer which is what this
talk has derived its name from so if you
aren't familiar with the like cultural
ethos or the cultural context behind
this term
uh this tweet by sheikhar karani I'm
gonna throw them under the bus a bit uh
really really captures this in my in my
opinion uh he's basically figured out
like here's a bunch of
um proxy behaviors that these tedx
Engineers follow and let me characterize
them just by these proxy metrics so he
says stuff like
10x Engineers don't go to meetings they
think it's a waste of time
tedx Engineers are extremely irregular
they don't work when other people are
around 10x Engineers have black laptop
background screens uh I thought this was
satire when I first read it but I think
it really just points to the fact that
we've developed this culture with within
engineering where tedx Engineers are
viewed as uh only technical only
technical prowess is valued above all
else right at the expense of everything
else and as a result we've tolerated
these extremely
uh toxic behaviors
um basically like if you watch Silicon
Valley like the guilfoils of Silicon
Valley right
um yes they are incredibly uh
intelligent but everything else that
they do is absolutely terrible and and
reduces productivity uh now obviously
being an amazing technical contributor
is a great thing like I'm not trying to
say that you shouldn't try to do that
um but even if you subscribe to that
notion for engineering my main point
here
is that this has no place in analytics
and this will basically be the the
thrust of the talk so the primary reason
I'm arguing for this is that our
strongest levers are not technical so
unlike engineering where you're often
you know given a project you you have to
execute on that project in the most
elegant way possible and then deliver
that to production we have this whole
workflow that exists outside of just
doing the technical work right so on one
side of it on the conception side of
things we are our own PMS right we are
the ones who dictate our own roadmap
unless you have a data PM or something
like that
um meaning that this unless you believe
that believe that PMS are absolutely
useless uh there's a very strong lever
here to do prioritization against your
own work
uh secondly on the consumption side of
things obviously we're we're an
interfacial discipline right right like
Engineers they can just ship to prod
done it's it's I mean they might have
bugs they might have QA to do but most
for the most part it's just production
grade right it's production ready but
for us our work is is interfacial we
work with stakeholders but but it's also
contingent right like our our work is
the value of our work is predicated on
its reception and it's use by other
people like we're not the ones making
decisions we're not the ones driving
strategy but we are constructing the
knowledge ecosystems within which other
people are able to to make those
decisions drive that strategy so there's
a lot of uh value there as well unless
of course you believe your executives
are not valuable but that's another talk
um
so all in all my point here is analytics
is not purely a technical domain so that
the concept of a 10x engineer the purely
technical engineer doesn't doesn't quite
fit here
uh so how do we be tedx analysts I
really love this tweet by Andrew Terrio
where he says if you divine 10x in terms
of code you're doing it wrong
um the extra contribution comes from
being really great at something other
than code so domain architecture product
something like that during this talk I
will explore what those are and give you
my take on what I believe those levers
are
[Music]
um
all right so now I'm going to tell you a
little bit about myself uh Carlos gave
me a great introduction so I'll just
Breeze through this but as you mentioned
I was in grad school this is where I got
my start in data
um I call this my terrible life choice
time of life I I studied Rivers which
was fantastic but I also stole a lot of
food from graduate school seminars
survived off of that eventually got a
life raft to a company called Wayfair
where I did a lot of causal inference
work causal uplift modeling you might
know me from an uplift modeling library
that I created called pylift I then went
on to Airbnb this was my I want to be
closer to the business phase
um
got to work in more General data science
got to do a bit of causal inference as
well but also got to be very close to uh
the product analytics side of things
which was a lot of fun got to open
source some stuff along the way as well
while doing the product analytics things
I realized that the workflow here was
horrendous and so I went over to the
dark side and I became a Founder
also a PM so I guess I'm like doubly on
the dark side so I'm I'm at hyper query
I co-founded this with a couple folks
and we're building a data notebook
purpose built for analytics purpose
built to solve the problems in analytics
I'll get into that very briefly at the
end
um but yeah basically I'm a PM now uh
that's why the axes aren't labeled
that's my excuse
um all right so
let's talk about how to be a 10x analyst
before I really get into this I want to
give you all a disclaimer I use Twitter
to crowdsource this talk so if you're a
pessimist you can view this as oh my God
he cheated if you're an optimist you can
view this as like like wisdom of the
crowds I'm just thank you
all right let's move on uh but if you
see a bunch of tweets this is why
because I'm I'm you know a few of you
are actually in here so I'll I'll maybe
I'll call you out maybe I won't
um
so the eigen question below how do we be
a 10x analyst is is what are we actually
10xing even so I want to approach this
from a more like analytics analysis
perspective I really love this tweet by
Drew muffston where he says like is this
a talk with a real meta question is
hidden how do you measure the impact of
a data team and this is so right uh we
need to Define this first we need to
correctly think about what is our
objective then Define the metric etc etc
so our objective plain and simple is
business value right uh and I'm going to
pause because I think I mean for me at
least this isn't
this is something that we know in our
heart of hearts but we often don't
really think about we don't internalize
we don't actually act on but if you're
not providing business value you're not
providing business value right so
tautologically you need to be providing
business value uh so I think we all know
that let's move on
but I'm going to break this down in a
way that I think you guys haven't seen
before this is like a common breakdown
in analytics you know you you break down
a metric into its drivers in this case
I'm going to break down business value
into impact times reach so I think we're
all familiar with impact you know effect
on Top Line metrics how much revenue did
you drive as an analytics team
that's already really hard to measure
and well you know I'm happy to talk
about that more later
um but this is this side of it is
basically just you know direct Delta
impulse effect on your metrics right
what what decision did you impact uh
what outcome did you help Drive what
decision did you help make and then on
the other side of things I'm introducing
this term which is reach so this is how
many people how many decisions did this
scalably impact and this is a less
commonly thought of uh uh driver but
just as important nonetheless like if
you can yes if you can drive some impact
yourself that's fantastic but if you can
get someone else to also have that take
that learning and drive that impact as
well obviously you've just doubled your
impact right so this is a strong lever
as well
um so if we all agree to this I mean
it's a talk so you guys can't disagree
let's just move on
uh then the answer is quite simple to be
a 10x analyst you just have to pursue
impact you have to pursue reach right
you have to take these two drivers and
you pump them both up
so for the rest of the talk I will will
go through these and talk about how to
actually you know Drive Impact how to
actually drive reach
all right
um a quick step back to my again to
remind you of the ridiculous bit that I
had in the beginning
um if you look at the I promise you that
if you look at the things that I said
were ways to sabotage your team they're
actually ways to lift your upper lip up
lift up your team as well so I just
wanted to go through those and just
validate that for you
so encourage others to work on
interesting projects with ambiguous
value this is basically driving down the
impact of others right while uh
uh on the other hand you could encourage
people to work on things that are
important right but this is obviously a
trap that we often fall into as analysts
we're like hey shot a new object let's
go do that because that's cool and that
will make me learn things but in reality
you shouldn't do that right number two
make it so your work can't be reused by
anyone else this is a reach problem
right you're pushing down the the impact
of your work to reach other people
obviously if you just flip that on its
head you'll end up with better reach so
all right so I'll go through each one of
these two drivers in turn and then we'll
we'll we'll uh talk about some more
General aspects of this so let's talk
about how to maximize impact
so the punchline is quite simple you
just got to pursue and prioritize your
work by impact as best as you can of
course right I really love this tweet by
Lauren balick so she says so in response
to my tweet about like how do you beat a
10x analyst she says you should report
into the c-suite and them alone
if you get bogged down with line of
business dashboards and stuff you're
doomed to doomed to that your value
decays with each end analysis
and this this is freaking ridiculous uh
so I you know I when I first heard this
I just I laughed I was like this is this
is absurd uh no one can can just do that
but you know she has a point right and
this is something we often don't think
about if you're making decisions say on
on higher strata you just end up having
higher impact right like you can imagine
let's say you were in a customer service
domain if you're working as an IC the
greatest impact you'll have is a few
percentage points when you you do a deep
dive analysis on an experiment right
um
but then if you're reporting into the
c-suite the oops
what did I just do okay
um
if you're reporting to the c-suite then
the level of decision that you're making
is like should we completely ask
customer service or should we not should
we drive double the the amount of
resources into it or not right and so
suddenly you you're working within
margins of like zero to two hundred
percent lift right
um well okay don't don't kill me again
I'm a piano PM don't don't kill me on
the hand wavy metrics uh so let's move
on
uh so the general point though that
Lauren is making is actually quite good
uh not that this point isn't good this
is quite good as well but she's pointing
to basically preeta law right power law
uh 80 20 rule uh so the basic idea is
that if you look at all the work that
you've done about 20 of them will drive
80 of the outcomes right you know very
roughly speaking uh and if you were to
actually do this if you were to take and
believe me like I've actually done this
I'm sure you guys can do this this
exercise yourself you go through and you
you look at a distribution of all the
projects that you've worked on as an
analyst uh and you rank order them
you'll find that there's this very thin
slice of projects that actually drove
substantial value for your business
um and so given that uh
given that
the answer is really you should figure
out how to seek out these these projects
right you should go how to seek out
these projects and capture that 20
effort
um and I'd say it's even more ridiculous
right like I've had a lot of uh work as
an analyst where I'm like oh yeah I just
answered a bunch of ad hoc requests for
like four months and this drove
absolutely no impact right
and I'm sure a lot of you have felt the
same
now the problem is that this is easier
said than done uh and I you know I'm I'm
here on my high horse giving this talk
about this but in reality I've like I've
never done this uh
so let's let's go to uh story time I'll
tell you a little bit about my time at
Airbnb which really spurred my doubt in
our ability to do this collectively so
when I was at Airbnb
uh I got I got pushed to work on
um on Australia right my my uh like data
management analytics management was like
Australia is is the golden land this is
where all the opportunities are for our
business let's go to Australia let's
analyze Australia so I looked uh I went
back to you know my managers my my um
uh data Executives et cetera et cetera
and I was like there's nothing here
there's nothing here they were like keep
looking keep looking there's something
there uh so I kept looking uh and
you know I even went to Australia I
talked to uh researchers I talked to
um I talked to actual hosts in Australia
and at the end of the day like three
months later I found that the the amount
of impact was Zero it was Zero the
impact was Zero there was nothing there
uh and I mean this was like you know you
guys know like the phrase um if you if
you torture data enough it'll confess
right like who's heard of that phrase
okay great so the common phrase
um this was like this was like the Liam
Neeson from Taken of data sets it was
like it was what was that quote it was
like I have a particular set of skills I
will find you I will look for you I will
find you and I will waste your time that
was this data set
uh and at the end of the day I was like
okay
I wasted three months on this this is
absolutely absurd uh but also my my
managers my my leadership they all
encouraged me to keep prying here
um
I think this points to the systemic
problem that we don't know what we're
doing like basically I went down this
rabbit hole and I dug into this right I
was like why did I waste my time you
guys tell me why I wasted my time on
this uh and it came down to like
Australians call things different words
and that probably leads to a bad user
experience and I was like what the what
the hell
um
basically I went down a rabbit hole
because Australians call adus Granny
Flats right and they thought that this
is where all the opportunity was and so
I started to get this inkling that
perhaps data people don't have great
product intuition uh
and then I I I went on a very very dark
Rabbit Hole so I'll continue with this
this slide show
um so what I did next is what I I what I
did next was I prioritized all of our
projects or I looked at all of our
projects and I rank ordered them by what
we were excited about and then uh rank
ordered them also by uh uh what was the
most impactful so in the last year what
we've done
and the first thing you might notice is
that nothing in the left column is
actually in the right column so there
was just really I mean I didn't do a
rigorous analysis on this but there was
basically no correlation right at the
end of the day you can see the Australia
thing here a couple other projects we're
excited about here we ended up working
on all these things that we were and
heavily investing in all these things
that we were personally very excited
about that we personally thought were
interesting and maybe impactful at the
same time uh but our most impactful
projects were quite different so
just to read off a couple of these the
single most impactful thing that we did
was we found that in India the address
bar was just covering the submit button
so we fixed that it was this basic basic
simple funnel analysis right we also
looked into our live chat we realized
that on a deep dive there was actually
no no real value there uh so we we
canceled that saving millions of dollars
um
this last one uh I think you can
probably all guess but Airbnb during
covet is is a really difficult business
to be in
um so understatement right uh you know
you can imagine if people are if the CDC
is telling you don't don't get near
anyone or you will die you don't really
want to stay in anyone else's houses
um so during during the pandemic a big
analytics project that we did was we
just tried to figure out where we could
drive
targeted Supply to try to save the
business and you know maybe it
contributed to us riding the storm right
um
I don't know what the measure of value
there is but maybe it's the entire
business uh I don't want to attribute
too much value to analytics though so
let's move on
um
but the point here is prioritizing by
impact is just it's hard right like we
we a full team of us we just weren't
very good at this uh we we basically
tend to get distracted by shiny objects
right we we know that impact is our
North Star uh but rarely is that common
in our in our discourse in our daily
prioritization right
uh so how to do it just do it and I'm
going to repeat this a few times just
just do it just prioritize just do I
feel like I feel like that that gif but
really just prioritize my impact right I
think it needs to be said uh just
because we we just really tend not to
think about it right when we're bogged
down in operational details in
reactivity and working with our
stakeholders and making them happy we
just forget that this is important and
completely throw it out the window right
um so obviously that's not particularly
useful so I'll give you a couple tips
and this is all really common advice but
I'm going to tie it back to how it can
help you with impact uh so that way it's
a little bit more tangible
tip one get business documents so this
is one of the uh most important things I
think a lot of people say you should
have domain expertise you should think
about the business you should have full
context on the business but uh the
that's helpful in a number of ways but
one of the strongest levers is that it
can just help you identify what's high
leverage and what's not right like if
you actually understand the business you
can figure out hey this one actually uh
resonates with a lot of the customer
requests that we're getting or a lot of
the user research that we've been doing
maybe we should work on that first right
um
number two seek analysis business fit so
obviously on the other end of things our
work isn't valuable until it's actually
used so rather than just creating
something in a silo and delivering it
what you can do is really focus on on
seeking uh on creating something that's
actually tangibly useful to the rest of
your your organization right work with
your stakeholders directly figure out
what they need make sure that what the
decisions that they're making will
actually be informed by your work not
just you don't just create something
that's interesting to yourself
all right so part two let's talk about
how to maximize reach
uh so I'll start with two really obvious
statements here
um again I mean this whole talk is
pretty obvious so uh hopefully it's just
uh digging out things that you guys
already know and the depths of your
heart uh but one analyzes are more just
more useful when discoverable
um
number two dashboards are more useful
when uh maintained
so the best way to get reach then is to
figure out how to make sure that your
work is useful in these ways to other
people right
and so for analyzes this means you
should be sharing and centralizing your
work so really figuring out how it might
be used to drive other other patterns of
usage other Inspire other analyzes
impact other decisions how the learnings
can be transferred et cetera et cetera
and then for dashboards just maintain
the service right just make make less
dashboards and just make sure they don't
break so that way people don't have to
sift through thousands of dashboards
like I mentioned before right make sure
they feel they can trust this to
self-serve themselves
um I really I want to point this out
because I really love the this Chuck
Cassius tweet where he says uh I think
there's generally an outsized focus on
individual performance in all of us
culture I found that my best work uh is
one one comes one done in Graceville
concert with another person or a small
group where a contributions blend and
amplify I love this because I think we
don't all internalize uh how much of an
impact just disseminating our work
evangelizing our work sharing it with
others uh inspiring other people can
actually help I mean we basically have
this this uh network of of people and if
you were to just get one other person to
have the same lift that you did then
obviously there's a if everyone were to
do that there's a exponential increase
right in your value
all right so to sum up everything uh
three main points that I wanted you to
get out of this talk uh one you should
be prioritizing your work by impact and
the best way to do this and the best tip
I have for you is to invest in business
Acumen to make sure you can identify the
high leverage projects
number two make sure your impactful work
is actually used so work very closely
alongside the rest of the business to
make sure context is transferred there's
a very very tight coupling between how
your work will be used it's delivered
well
um
Etc et cetera and then finally make sure
your work is useful to others so for
analyzes document them and then for
dashboards maintain them
all right so I want to one last point
that I want to make is I just want to
flip these on their head and and point
to the problems that these point to and
just have a more like macroscopic
discussion about this
um
so prioritized by impact the problem the
root problem the root evil behind this
is like we just are bad at prioritizing
uh in terms of uh pushing you to align
with your stakeholders better the
problem that this points to is we have
poor alignment and then on the like
making your your work useful to others
the the problem that this points to is
just chaos like we have just utter chaos
in our in our teams right now
the problem here is imagine you're
imagine you're a product manager right
and you're you're you see a data team
that functions like this uh you'd be
like okay they can't they can't figure
out uh what to work on they they don't
actually drive much value they they
don't align with me to figure out what I
I believe that they should do
um and everything is chaotic I can't
find any of the things that they've done
if you put yourself in that person's
shoes you would just obviously be like
okay well I can't trust the analytics
team right so overall
this I think is the pattern of behavior
that leads to this this terrible
reactivity this this degradation of of
trust that we have with our stakeholders
right we end up becoming service orgs
rather than being
um the PowerHouse behind our our
organization that we could be if we were
to function really really seamlessly uh
this leads to overreactivity we end up
being sequel monkeys we end up being
pulled into these meetings where our
only role is to act as a SQL mechanic
just pushing the button and getting data
out right
um so this is I want to point to this
because this is not just
obviously like I want you all to be 10x
analysts uh but there's a bigger battle
that we're fighting right and this is
like the Battle of our domain we want to
make sure that we are uh uh uh really
transforming how the organization works
right there's organization-wide
repercussions here
um
so do it just just do these do these do
these things okay it'll help all of us
that's my point
um
so with that said I wanted to give a
little bit of advice to uh leads and
managers those who are in a manager
managerial position
for those of you who are familiar with
the 10x engineer Trope you probably have
heard of the idea that yeah you don't
want to just make yourself 10x you could
just make 10 other people 2X and then
that achieves the same goal
um the point there being that managers
have a really outsized opportunity to
drive this sort of Leverage across their
organization so two bits of advice that
I'd push for
One Mentor others to think in this way
sorry
excuse me Mentor others to think in this
way and you know I think you you would
think that this would be obvious but
again Australia example it's not always
obvious sometimes your managers will
Mentor you to
torture data instead just please don't
do that to your your reports it's it's
very discouraging and secondly I'd
encourage you to make this easier for
everyone so so obviously there's a
philosophy here
um below that there are processes and
rituals that you can Implement to reduce
the friction to to complying with this
sort of behavior right maybe make
templates maybe make documentation
um
basically ingrained this so that way
it's standard practice all these things
are standard practice Force alignment
with your stakeholders right force
people to ask why
um etc etc
all right
so that's the end of the talk uh and now
I'm going to tell you about hyper query
because again I'm a founder and I want
to sell things to you so uh I'm the
chief product officer and co-founder of
hyperquery and obviously I believe in
everything above uh but you know you can
you can choose whether or not to believe
me or not we make it easier to do 10x
work so
obviously we can't solve all of your
problems for you that's ridiculous we
can't solve prioritization for you you
have to do that yourself uh but we did
we did build this from the ground up to
make it a lot easier to reduce the
friction to doing a lot of these things
that are better behaviors so we make it
easier to share work we make it make it
easier to organize centralized work
um basically just dropping the friction
to make it so doing the things that make
you 10x are actually uh simple if you
have questions about this let me know
you can visit hyperquare.ai to learn
more or just come find me and I will
always talk about this
uh as much as you want
all right that's it thanks for your time
foreign